- [Voiceover] So I have
the function g here.
It's expressed as a
fourth degree polynomial.
And I wanna think about the
intervals over which g is
either concave upwards
or concave downwards.
Now let's just remind ourselves
what these things look like.
So concave,
concave upwards
is an interval,
an interval when you're concave upwards
is an interval over which
the slope is increasing
and it tends to look like an
upward opening U like that.
And you can see here that the
slope over here is negative,
and then as x increases,
it becomes less negative,
it actually approaches
zero, it becomes zero,
then it crosses zero and
becomes slightly positive,
more positive, even more positive.
So you can see the slope
is constantly increasing.
And if you think about it
in terms of derivatives,
it means that you're first
derivative is increasing
over that interval.
And in order for your first
derivative to be increasing
over that interval, your second derivative
f prime prime of x, actually
let me write it as g,
because we're using g in this example.
In order for your first
derivative to be increasing,
your, let me write this.
So g,
so concave upward means
that your first derivative increasing,
increasing,
which means, which means
that your second derivative
is greater than zero.
And concave downward is the opposite.
Concave downward,
downward,
is an interval, or you're
gonna be concave downward
over an interval when
your slope is decreasing.
So g prime of x is decreasing
or we can say that our second derivative,
our second derivative is less than zero.
And once again, I can draw it on this.
So, when x is lower, we have a, look,
or it looks like we have a positive slope,
then it becomes less positive,
and then it becomes less positive,
as it's approaching zero, it becomes zero,
then it becomes negative,
then even more negative,
and then even more negative.
So as you can see, our slope
is constantly decreasing
as x increases here.
So in order to think about the intervals
where g is either concave
upward or concave downward,
what we need to do is let's
find the second derivative of g,
and then let's think about the points
at which the second, where
the second derivative can go
from being positive to negative
or negative to positive
and those will be places
where it's either undefined
or where the second
derivative is equal to zero,
and let's see what's happening
in the interval between.
And then we'll know over what intervals
are we concave upward or concave downward.
So let's do that.
So let's take the first
derivative, g prime of x,
just gonna apply the power rule a lot.
Four times negative one
is negative four x to the
third power plus, okay,
so you're gonna have two times six
is plus 12x to the first power,
you can just write it as x.
And then minus two, I could say
minus two x to the zeroth power,
but that's just minus two.
And then the derivative of
negative three, of a constant
is just zero.
And now I can take the second
derivative, g prime prime of x
is going to be equal to
three times negative four
is negative 12x squared,
decrement the exponent plus 12.
And so let's see, where
could this be undefined?
Well, the second derivative
is just a quadratic expression
here which would be defined for any x.
So it's not going to
be undefined anywhere.
So, interesting points
where we could transition
from going from a negative to a positive
or a positive to a
negative, second derivative
is where this thing
could be equal to zero.
So let's figure that out.
So let's figure out where
negative 12x plus 12
could be equal to zero.
See, we could subtract 12 from both sides
and we get negative 12x squared
is equal to negative 12.
Divide both sides by negative 12,
you get x squared is equal to one
or x could be equal to the plus or minus,
or x could be equal to the plus
or minus square root of one,
which is, of course, just one.
So, at the second derivative
at plus or minus one
is equal to zero, so either
between plus or minus one
or on either side of
them, we are going to be,
we could be concave upward
or concave downward.
So let's think about this.
And to think about this, I'm
gonna make a number line.
Let me find a nice, soothing color here.
All right, that's a nice, soothing color.
And, let's say, we should
make the number line
a little bit bigger.
So, there we go, let's
utilize the screen space.
And so, if this is zero
and this is negative one,
this is negative two,
this is positive one,
this is positive two.
We know that at x equals negative one
and x equals one, our second
derivative is equal to zero.
So let's think about what's happening
in between those places to
see if our second derivative
is positive or negative, and
from that we'll be able to say
where it's concave upward
or concave downward.
So, on this first
interval right over here,
so this is the interval from,
this is the interval where we're going
from negative infinity to negative one.
Well, let's just try a
value in that interval
to see what whether our second derivative
is positive or negative.
And let's see, an easy value
there could be negative two,
it's in that interval,
so let's take g prime
prime of negative two,
which is equal to negative 12 times four,
because negative two
squared is positive four.
So it's negative 48 plus 12,
so it's equal to negative 36.
The important thing to realize, then,
is well, if over here it's negative,
then over this whole interval,
because it's not crossing through zero,
or it's not discontinuous
at any of these points,
that's why we picked this interval.
That over this whole interval,
g prime prime of x is less than zero,
which means that over this interval
we are concave downwards.
So concave, concave downward,
concave downward.
Now let's go to the interval
between negative one and one.
So this is the open interval
And let's try a value there.
Let's just try zero
will be easy to compute,
g prime prime of zero, well,
when x is zero, this is zero,
so it's just gonna be equal to 12.
The important thing to realize
is our second derivative here
is greater than zero, so
we are concave upward,
concave upward on this interval
between negative one and one.
And then finally, let's
look at, let's look at
the interval where x is greater than one.
So this is the interval
from one to infinity,
if we want to do it that way.
And let's just try a value.
Let's try g prime prime of two,
'cause that's in the interval.
And g prime prime of two
is gonna be the same thing
as g prime prime of negative two,
'cause whether you have a
negative two or a positive two,
you square it becomes four.
So you're gonna have
four times negative 12,
which is negative 48 plus
12, which is negative 36.
So this is negative 36, and
so, once again on this interval
you are concave, concave downward.
Now let's, I graphed this ahead of time,
let's see if what we just
established is actually consistent
with what the graph actually looks like.
We were able to come up
with these, these insights
about the concavity without graphing it.
But now, it's kind of satisfying
to take a look at a graph
and actually let me see if I
can match up the intervals.
Actually this is pretty closely matched,
all right over here.
And so, this is,
actually we can make it a
little bit smaller, all right.
And so, let me move my boundy box.
So, I'm saying that I'm concave downward
between negative infinity,
negative infinity
all the way until, all the
way until negative one,
all the way until this
point right over here.
So, all the way until that point.
And that looks right.
It looks like the slope
is constantly decreasing
all the way until we get
to x equals negative one,
and then the slope starts increasing.
The slope starts increasing from there,
from there all the way,
and right at x we're transitioning,
so I'm gonna leave a little,
I won't color in that.
And so here our slope is increasing,
let me do that same color.
Our slope is increasing,
increasing, increasing,
increasing, increasing all the way
until we get to x equals one.
And then our slope
starts decreasing again.
And we get back into concave downwards.
Oops, I wanna do that
in that orange color.
We get back into concave downwards.
So what we're able to figure out
by just taking the derivatives
and doing a little algebra,
we can see quite clearly
looking at the graph.